if you are really passionate about
theater and you want to create
incredible work with incredible people
people Carnegie Mellon University is the
place to be an idea that we're always
exploring in the School of Drama is how
can we be better how can we be different
how can we make something more
interesting than what we made last time
everyone around you is just the best at
what they're doing in the world in the
country to know that that's happening it
just makes you want to work as hard as
you possibly can
the School of Drama is the first a
conservatory training program within a
university in the country we actually
look at ourselves as a graduate program
in an undergraduate level I think
there's a great deal of care taken with
each individual student that the journey
that they're on is the one they thought
they were on and is a stimulating and
rewarding one the School of Drama does
about 17 productions of us there at
various scales so the more senior you
you move through the school probably the
larger responsibility you take it all
layers from the beginning we are very
very clear here that we don't have just
actors and a whole group of people
supporting actors that is not our
mission whatsoever there's a lot more to
drama and the School of Drama than just
the performance based majors we've gone
to great lengths to try to make sure
that the experience of a design student
or the experience of a production
student is equally important as the
experiences of any performance student
we do 100% of the work that goes on our
stages as student produce work we're
here until 10:30 at night actually
running a professional theater that's
probably the best experience you can get
just being in the rehearsal space and
watching and understanding what everyone
else's role is some people call it
theater boot camp
and the students who come here love that
you know that's what they're here for
that's the thing that drives them one of
the things that's most important to me
is getting our students off campus and
seeing theater around town because
they're some very good producing
organizations Pittsburgh provides a
beautiful laboratory for the exploration
of the other arts I've never been in a
faculty or in an academic setting where
I felt that the students were so central
they know exactly how to work with each
and every person individually and we get
so much individual attention seeing
their work and seeing them work outside
of this school is great because we know
that what they're telling us is in isn't
just from a textbook that was read in 50
years ago this degree will get you
anywhere this degree is a golden ticket
especially because of our alumni and and
the list is so long we have I think the
best alumni network anywhere our alumni
are the most generous group of human
beings that I think I've ever
encountered it's pretty inspiring to see
what people from here have gone on to do
and where they work
the Alumni clans in New York City and
Los Angeles are very strong which was
some another thing that really drew me
to the school because our alumni are so
well known when somebody picks up a
resume that has Carnegie Mellon
University School of Drama on it it
means something and they know that a
student who has graduated from Carnegie
Mellon University School of Drama is
well disciplined is well trained is
educated is bright and it's going to be
at the top of their game you got to
bring your a-game you got to perform you
got to show that you can do it but in a
business where it is very hard to get
doors open Cardinal it opens door
you